et pour les événements sportifs comme
pour le milieu des arts les spectateurs
pourront bientôt être plus nombreux à
compter du 3 où on fera passer de 50 à
250 le nombre de personnes permise dans
les lieux publics à condition de
respecter les consignes de santé
publique bonne nouvelle notamment pour
les théâtres quoique la réouverture ne
sera pas facile on va en discuter avec
ginette noiseux et les directrice
générale et artistique du théâtre espace
go merci d'être là madame d'oiseaux
bonsoir merci le secteur du
divertissement évidemment c'est l'un des
plus touchés par la pandémie est ce que
c'est un soulagement pour vous cette
autorisation de rassemblement 250
personnes c'est un soulagement par la
mesure où on doit respecter la
distanciation de 2 m un mètre et demi
mais il faut comprendre que les
pratiques ou des fauteuils ont des
mesures qui s'adapte pas à un mètre et
demi ou deux mains en gros on reste à 2
m pour les spectateurs mais pour dessein
de création qu'on était âpre espace go
le théâtre d'aujourd'hui le théâtre de
quat'sous le la licorne câble de bain
comme on parle d'à peu près et 50 à 60
spectateurs par soir ont des plus
grandes salles comme d'un syndicat du
nouveau monde ou de théâtre jean-duceppe
250 personnes doit être un grand
soulagement
mais on comprend bien qu'on est dans une
année expérimentale
on est dans une année de solidarité et
que pour ces grains de sable s'est
rapidement du 6 mai mais on sera
tellement on vous y allez être au rendez
vous mais pas tout de suite si je
comprends bien vous n'aviez pas prévu
rouvrir cet été est ce que cette annonce
ne change la donne j'ai eu des
discussions assez costaud avec le
cabinet de la ministre eurois 9 rod est
apprécié pour un acteur ou une actrice
en 80 heures de répétitions c3 de
préparation une saison si on ya deux ans
de planification dont non c'est pas
c'est pas mon guide sujets ont fait ces
musiciennes
je suis toujours épaté
le voir prendre on sait que ces femmes
puissent partir pour faire ça il ya deux
ans le karotz est une horloge suisse
oui donc ça prend trois mois dès ce
parcours va réouvrir le vercors
on a commencé les premières lectures on
commence les premières répétitions dans
des conditions aussi de sécurité
sanitaire pour les acteurs les actrices
dans deux mâles de distance et on passe
sur un gros gros travail un travail de
longue haleine des pertes entre temps
qui s'accumulaient ce que les mesures
d'urgence vous ont aidé pas les
institutions pour l'instant honnêtement
je pense que tout le monde a été dépassé
qu'on y fasse à un gouvernement qui
acquiesce est un jeune gouvernement avec
des personnes qui sont nouvellement en
poste est compté comme tout le monde
complètement dépassé par la situation
mais c'est assez inquiétant l'absence de
leader si oui est-ce qu'un creux temps
vous avez des donateurs qui vous et puis
alors c'est aussi le système de
financement
aujourd'hui au québec et depuis toujours
on cela va faire bientôt 40 ans et tu
dans le métier est fondée sur le
partenariat public privé donc une grande
partie de nos finances marc vient du
privé et j'aime à rappeler à tous les
spectateurs et spectatrices d aviva mais
ce n'est pas nous qui sommes
subventionnés ce sont leurs billes et ea
si on devait charger le pré prix comme à
new york
ce serait pas 30 dollars et bien est-ce
par gommer 125 $ par soir donc comment
continuer de recevoir ses spectateurs et
spectatrices à un prix abordable
avec évidemment l'entreprise privée est
un très très grand public n'est pas au
rendez vous oui ça c'est un autre
problème est ce que vous croyez
dans ce contexte là où il ya beaucoup de
pression financière où vous serez pas à
pleine capacité ce que c'est c'est
possible de redevenir rentable table
des bibliothèques sont pas rentables la
culture éprouvante à la pensée pas
rentable
les hôpitaux sont pas rentables on a
fait un choix de société au québec au
canada d'offrir une qualité de vie
intellectuelle
tous les citoyens citoyennes donc ça ne
sera jamais mais repose la question
autrement aide pendant combien de temps
vous allez pouvoir tenir ma danoise où
la plupart des compagnies étaient hansen
en scène un situation ne supporte des
terrains en cette situation parce qu on
est tellement habitués à surveiller
chaque sou oui je pense qu'on peut tenir
jusqu'au printemps prochain
bon on va s'accrocher dans ces
circonstances là dessus ni que l'espace
rond et très soutenu par l'entreprise
privée depuis toujours les mécènes
saurait s'en sont allés coupe on va
sauter ça reste comme ça merci beaucoup
madame noiseuse merci